émilie nicolas jonathan trudeau luc
ferrandez bonsoir
notre collègue jean télé hier revenait
sur cette question de d'attenté pour une
chirurgie avait cette dame de mont
laurier cattin pour le coeur c'est un
qui est temporel les listes s'allongent
aujourd'hui on fait le tour des chiffres
sur les urgences ça s'est empiré je vous
donne un seul tableau là on est rendu à
plus de 16 heures d'attentes sur une
civière et c'était
13h42 2017-2018 15h15 en 2019 en bon
est-ce qu'on va parler jusqu'à notre
mort est ce qu'on va trouver une façon
émilie nicolas au québec de régler ça un
jour est-ce que sur le plan plus
politique terre à terre est ce que c'est
un boulet hypotension pour le
gouvernement que les gens sont pas
désabusé mais presque émile
mais ça fait des décennies que son que
sont comme ça des gens comme moi ils
sont trop jeunes pour se souvenir d'une
époque où ce n'était pas comme ça donc
c'est sûr que ça l'impact sur les ondes
attentes des gens ceci dit ça y est ça
reste complètement inacceptable qui en
fait qu'il y ait eu plusieurs et
plusieurs d'entre eux par un parasol
premièrement laquelle sont délestages
avec la pandémie on a parlé beaucoup
durant le temps des fêtes c'est un sujet
qui est complètement disparu de des
consciences on dirait nos depuis depuis
la
fin de la 5e balle dont dirais que c'est
complètement à vue comme préoccupation
du gouvernement le goût quand il me
parle et qu'il était temps de réouvrir
et que la capacité hospitalière étaient
présentes l'autre impact ça là c'est un
discours qu'on voit de plus en plus
présente en par la course à la chefferie
conservatrice qu ici au québec sur le
rôle grandissant que le privé pourrait
prendre un système de santé donc à force
de porc et investir dès de normaliser
cette situation là les gens qui veulent
plus de privatisation se positionne pour
m m jardinot de l'avant et on voit
beaucoup avec notamment pierre poilievre
jean charest est aussi avec éric duhaime
au québec c'est un duo qui prend et
aussi prend soin de gauche de bordeaux
c'est un petit coup qui prend de plus en
plus oui parce que là quelque 10 il y
aura un rôle au privé a fermé en même
temps réinvestissement il y en a eu
quand même pas mal mais bon c'est
peut-être un au débat mais jonathan
première impression est ce que quand
vous êtes au gouvernement vous entendez
nouvelles comme ça vous êtes bon bain
dans deux jours les gens ils penseront
plus ou compte tenu qu'ils ont quand
même promis que ça allait être différent
comment ils se situent vis-à vis cette
réalité
soyons bien bien clair patrice il s'agit
d'une promesse briser la cohésion avenir
québec qui avait s'était engagé la main
sur le coeur a ramené le temps de
latence dans les urgences akoto de 12,5
heures au résultat des courses a
augmenté à chaque année depuis qu'ils
sont au pouvoir donc on peut faire ce
constat là c'est une promesse qui brise
et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
répondre pour se défendre et ils vont
parler évidemment de la pandémie qui a
eu un rôle qui a eu un rôle à jouer qui
a empêché lula m'a peut-être de fournir
un maximum d'efforts à s'attaquer à
cette problématique là et vous savez
quoi on peut estimer mais je vais leur
donner quand même le bénéfice du doute
parce que c'est évident que ce n'était
pas le bon moment avec une pandémie
mondiale jamais vue qui a duré deux
heures pour pour tout réformer donc je
pense que là tu ils ont beau jeu de le
dire maintenant il faudra offrir de de
sérieuses garanties et la bonne nouvelle
peut être pour le gouvernement c'est que
les québécois ont envie de croire qui
sert du bien on a vu les résultats -
sondage léger qui démontre que les
québécois pensent dans une proportion de
30 2% qu'est christian dubé et le
meilleur me disent la santé qu'on a eu
dans l'est dans les vingt dernières
années ils ont envie de croire aux
produits en même temps on voit que
l'optimisme est assis prudent mais la
caq encore encore plus de crédibilité
aux yeux des québécois je pense dans sa
volonté de faire changer les choses -
luc qu'en pensez vous bon d'abord vivre
avec la maladie vivent avec la pandémie
c'est ça que ça veut dire qu'à un moment
donné il va leur dire un consensus
québécois sur le fait que c'est un vrai
assez durs et il fallait faire des
choses autrement offre refusée
déconfinement majeur on avait refusé les
fermetures de restaurants de bars etc on
allait retourner à la normale et c'est
beaucoup moins coûteux pour le
gouvernement d'avoir des personnes
réparties un peu partout sur le
territoire qui n'ont pas accès à des
soins de santé que d'avoir une main deux
personnes qui se sent prise au piège par
un gouvernement trop contraignant
rappelez vous le déclare les
comparaisons avec la floride au monde
avec la philo dit oh mon dieu d'abord
les stades de sport complet puis nous on
n'est même pas capable de s'asseoir dans
un restaurant et donc la pression était
forte pour dire bon que des gens qu'ils
soient âgés ou qu'elle a commis beaucoup
mobilité meurt on va vivre avec mais le
confinement on veut plus vivre avec
ouais mais là vous comprenez que la
fleurette ce qu'il est en vie
quant à toronto puis cas dans toutes les
provinces canadiennes quand partout dont
on pourrait pas quand même au québec
vivre sous une douche sous un autre
rythme sanitaire totalement le cas mais
je ne dis pas je ne dis pas que c'était
pas la bonne décision à prendre vous
avez bien qu'il ya un consensus mais il
y avait même un consensus pour prendre
cette décision là mais une conséquence
quai
joly de jury doris mans a été assermenté
nouvelle députée hier
aujourd'hui on lui donne mandat spécial
je commence avec vous je n'attends pour
aller parce qu'on posait beaucoup la
question qu elle était élue elle est
infirmière puis elle est travaillée dans
la fiq toutefois connaît bien distincts
est-ce qu'ils vont l'utiliser est-ce
qu'ils vont
utiliser son sont sous son potentiel
pour essayer de régler réchaud ballon
lui donnait mandat d'aller faire des
visées dans les clean et jonathan cake
qu'est ce que vous en dites est ce que
c'est des relations publiques ou
réellement on veut entendre ce que cette
jeune députée a à dire
ben moi je pense il y avait une
intention qui qui est noble je pense pas
que le gouvernement serait suffisamment
cynique voire machiavélique pour dire
qu'on va faire semblant qu'on veut
l'utiliser mais dans les faits ça va
être uniquement un rôle un rôle de
façade la réalité c'est qu'on va le
savoir l usage s'arrête à madame doris
mots de démontrer qu'elle du point
qu'elle sait se faire entendre
évidemment ça prend deux grilles de
d'ouverture de la part du gouvernement
mais on en dit beaucoup de bien elle a
de l'expérience et la de la volonté mais
comprenons nous bien les lots 6 semaines
de session parlementaire pour amener le
où je pense que ce que madame de rythme
on peut faire c'est de contribuer entre
autres ce qui se reproduit comme
engagement lors de la prochaine campagne
électorale faudra pas s'attendre à ce
que les résultats de l'élection de
madame doris mandant marie-victorin
donne des résultats concrets par exemple
concret par exemple au niveau de
législatif au niveau réglementaire ça va
être un travail de longue haleine et
c'est l usage qu on va voir si
effectivement elle peut contribuer
favorablement aux travaux du grenelle
dont émilie
mail c'est sûr que c'est sûr que c'est
en voyant qu'on va le voir si je peux
résumer comme ça mais donne dans l'autre
côté il faut dire qu'il ya déjà une
adjointe parlementaire ou de la santé
c'est pas elle que l'élite et du rôle
donc c'est pas un poste officiel qu'on
lui donne il ya aussi toutes sortes de
mécanismes officielle à l'assemblée
nationale pour faire des consultations
avec la société ces personnes ont plus
qu on utilise son jeu fait le choix d'un
canal informel essentiellement d'envoyer
une députée faire une tournée sur le
terrain c'est une approche qui peut
avoir certains avantages qu'on veut
travailler rapidement mais c'est sûr
aussi que c'est une approche permet de
choisir ses interlocuteurs et de
s'assurer d'être en face de gens qui
nous disent qu'on voit pas ici c'est ce
que les gens veulent faire donc il ya
des avantages et des cours et des
comptes a donné un mandat à un député 5
et de lettre officielle de mandat
d'aucune façon que ce soir je pense que
c'est important de le
cclat faut lui donner un rôle qui
correspond à son arrivée c'est à dire
elle est toute nouvelle il faut lui
donner du temps je vais d'accord avec la
date à ce n'est pas du cynisme de dire
on va lui donner un rôle de basse
pression va voir mais par contre là où
il ya du cynisme c'est cette idée qu'on
va écouter le terreau est un instant la
réforme de la santé c'est un truc hyper
complet hyper complexe dans laquelle il
faut prendre en considération des enjeux
comme le rôle des médecins ou le ou de
la première dame qui d'autre que les
médecins peuvent faire un rôle de
première ligne quel rôle on va donner
aux infirmes et à quel rôle on va donner
aux cdc est ce que vraiment les côtes du
terrain va venir modifier ces grands
blocs là j'ai des gros doutes très bien
aujourd'hui
risi
dans la personne la mairie victoire et
il ya un élément qui souvent revenu dans
le discours du ministre dubé
ce premier ministre qui qui méritait un
peu c'est à dire que on disait on a
besoin d'une infirmière autour de la
table ça fait trop longtemps que le
réseau est géré par les médecins c'est
vrai que lorsqu'on regarde au niveau des
décideurs politiques trop souvent ça a
été des médecins par contre lorsqu'on
parle lorsque luc faire référence à
l'importance d'aller sur le terrain moi
il ya des échos que j'ai à l'effet que
les médecins m res aux 50 ans du oui
faut aller chercher la rétroaction des
infirmières des préposés aux
bénéficiaires mais de plus en plus on a
éloigné les médecins ddm d
de l'organisation si on veut du travail
fait que les ministères la santé pour
qu'eux aussi soient là pour leur dire
peut-être que nous si on est capable de
vous donner le pouls et vous dire ce qui
va se passer donc c'est bien beau dire à
l'émission de lui assez mais le pouls du
terrain les maisons aussi ont leur rôle
à jouer ils sont habitués jonathan est
très écouté il faut dire sont
habituelles très proche de 10 ministres
et tout ça on verra la suite je disais
que ce bérubé député du parti québécois
qui a dit écoutez on s'approche
peut-être au québec d'une crise
démocratique
il va rentrer aux députés élus de la cac
par rapport à l'opposition qui va être
décimée on écoute monsieur bérubé et la
réponse de monsieur legault
aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans une
situation avec les derniers sondages où
on peut anticiper une crise démocratique
importante au québec la cac avec un peu
plus de 40% des voix pourrait se
retrouver avec une centaine de sièges
sur 125 c'est une disproportion qui fait
peur comment va fonctionner le parlement
quelle sera la position qu'elle sera le
pouvoir sans précédent qu'on va confier
un gouvernement qui ne report apporter
la majorité quand on fait la liste des
priorités ce n'est pas une priorité pour
les québécois donc j'ai toujours dit que
j'écoute les québécois parce que
j'entends des québécois c'est à part
quelques
personnes qui sont dans la bulle
politique il n'ya pas de dap et
dissidents population en général pour
changer le mode de scrutin
parce qu'évidemment monsieur bérubé lui
ce qu'il plaidait c'est que ça a repris
un changement du mode de scrutin ce qui
avait été promis qu pas été fait on
attend c'est ça du côté de la cac pour
qui m
représentation minimale de l'opposition
tourne la tablature luc qu'est ce que ça
vous dit
notre notre système fonctionne très bien
quand il ya deux partis principaux mais
qui s'affrontent puis qui ont à peu près
des scores qui s'approche à 10% à partir
du moment où tu as plein partis qui ont
10% et au donc aucune chance de se faire
élire et que le gros la caq avec 40% va
chercher le gros des députés ça devient
effectivement un problème démocratique
ça veut dire que le parti québécois avec
des tongs 10% des votes va avoir un
député le parti libéral avec 15% des
votes béton avec quatre co députés donc
c'est ça va être complètement
inéquitable d'une part mais surtout ça
va empêcher de l'expression de voix et
d'idées et de principes et de demandes
qui sont légitimes jonathan mais tant
que le système ne change pas puis ne
changera pas le mode de scrutin
s'il évite à pionne prime aux meneurs
effectivement si en plusieurs parties
absolument et c'est dans la tradition
c'est à dire que lorsque vous n'êtes pas
pouvoir le modèle il ne vous convient
pas lorsque vous êtes au pouvoir qu'ils
ont permis d'arrêter lui majoritairement
vous êtes plus facilement capable de
vous en contenter mais en même temps on
va se le dire c'est une discussion qui
mène un peu nulle part parce que le
réforme du mode de scrutin y sera
évidemment pas changé pour l'élection du
3 octobre prochain imaginez le directeur
général des élections avait dit qu'il
fallait que le projet de loi de son
label soit adoptée en février
2021 pour lui donner le temps de mettre
en place ce nouveau système le donc
essentiellement ce que pascal bérubé
fait c'est pas dire il faut changer le
mode de scrutin c'est de dire attention
on court peut-être
le risque de voir le parti québécois
disparaître parce que dans les faits
c'est sale c'est qui voit qu'avec la
répartition actuelle le parti québécois
seraient peut-être condamné à voir dans
le meilleur des scénarios un ou deux
sièges dont six équipes davantage la
disparition du parti québécois je pense
que de l'omniprésence de la cac et au
salon bleu emilie
mais c'est sûr que le parti québécois
aussi lui-même pas impuni a mis en place
la réforme est
l'occasion de faire alors que c'est dans
leur parti donc effectivement ça semble
être une espèce de maladies des partis
au pouvoir ceci dit je pense que la
question plus fondamentale c'est qu'on a
hérité d'un système démocratique
britannique qui est fait pour
fonctionner les bleus contre les rouges
avec une chambre du peuple il a une
chambre dès lors qu'il a plus la société
évolue plus la société change placées et
et expirant du modèle du modèle qui es
tu là de la monarchie considérée
britanniques puis on se ramasse avec des
problèmes des problèmes de
fonctionnement qu'on peut essayer de
repenser les choses tout en gardant tout
en forme je parle pas là la boîte
essentiellement le modèle à penser ce
qu'on veut de parfaire les capitaux
fixes sont là puis c'est sûr que pour
les gens qui va faire ça parce que vous
êtes avec raison emilie le pq la veille
bon là qu'elle voulait faire trudeau
voulait faire la peau fait qui va faire
ça
mais en ce moment le parti qu'en corse
et dans sa plate forme puisque jamais
pris le pouvoir fait si québec solidaire
les hôtes ont tous eu l'occasion de
prendre le pouvoir puis finalement
changé d'idée une fois qu'ils étaient au
pouvoir donc c'est donc c'est la seule
option qui a pas été testés mais ceci
dit c'est sûr que c'est une question ne
faut par contre quelques justement
l'image dans les autobus demande sept
ans je demande cette réforme là parce
que c'est abstrait on demande pas aux
gens qu'est ce qu'on veut faire pour
changer vos vies on demande comment
faire pour changer le mécanisme qui
permet d'affecter les décisions que
changent nos vies donc c'est sûr que
dans 1 2 de niveau d'abstraction comme
ça l'est beaucoup de gens qui débarquent
puis aussi quand on pose aux jambes
ainsi on change la réponse on change de
scrutin c'est quoi le mode de scrutin
alternatif qu'on veut mais là c'est sûr
aussi qu'il faut avoir des gros débat là
dessus qu'ils sont des bottes qu'ils
peuvent être technique pour les gens qui
sont pas initiés un peuple encore une
fois ça devient des buts initié pour
paul et pour la population générale -
jonathan et le clac eu
évidemment qu'une telle réforme le désir
d'une telle réforme ne viendra jamais du
peuple de la base le jonathan va pas les
repas des pétitions pour que ça se fasse
non mais en même temps le peuple son mot
à dire là dessus il ya un élément que je
trouvais intéressant dans la façon que
le gouvernement le goût avait évolué sur
cette question là avant la pandémie et
celles qui ont décidé de mettre de côté
karim al le projet de loi mais c'est
cette idée d'abord un référendum d'abord
parce que quand même on parle de la
chose est plus fondamental en démocratie
c'est comment on va choisir les gens qui
vont nous gouvernent qui vont nous
gouverner qui vont nous représenter je
sais que certains auraient voulu qu'on
fait à la va vite sous prétexte que
justement les gens ça les intéresse
pautex mais moi je pense que ce sera
fondamental éventuellement oui de se
pencher sur cette question là de le
faire correctement et s'assurer qu'on
est l'adhésion de la population pour
changer la façon dont on voit élire ne
représente pas ce qu'on ne voit pas
l'udc à court terme le retour des bleus
des rouges comme on disait justement
deux gros parfum non content
ici comme ailleurs dans le monde le vote
dit vie sauve aux états unis avec leurs
deux grands partis mais le vote se
divisant viennent d'avoir en france
aussi et les conservateurs
entre angers mais tellement plus que
mettons une moyenne de 12% travers le
québec québec solidaire est ce qu'on
peut s'attendre à ce qu'ils représentent
un jour 40 pour cent cinquante euros
n'en doute alors là qu'à la question qui
vont implanter système local et le
gouvernement qui arriverait à en place
qui dirait ma première priorité moi
c'est de plus en entendre l'opposition
parce que c'est une opposition plus 10
et une opposition divisée qui représente
une grande part de la population
certainement pas la cac la cac qui a
tout fait pour faire taire l'opposition
depuis au moins deux ans mais comme on
le disait personne n'est allé de ce côté
là était monsieur trudeau non plus qui
avait pourtant preniez la chose ne l'a
pas fait merci beaucoup emilie jonathan
look intéressant à la prochaine au
revoir au revoir soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit